[Música]
y seguramente hablar de economía me
acompaña ya esta hora en el estudio o
jorge hurtado jorge vamos a hablar de la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económico hablamos de la osce
de que presentó su previsión de
crecimiento mundial nada alentador a esa
previsión cayó este año precisamente por
el tema de la guerra en ucrania que está
moviendo todas las actividades
económicas del mundo en abril de este
año la organización mantenía su
proyección de crecimiento mundial en 4,5
por ciento pero tan sólo dos meses
después el panorama se vuelve un poco
más sombrío para la economía global y
baja al 3% en el informe el organismo se
muestra crítica con rusia asimismo dicen
que la principal urgencia ahora es
impedir una crisis alimentaria que
podría afectar a los países más pobres
del mundo la zona euro es la más
afectada en diciembre habían proyectado
un incremento del pib del 4.3 por ciento
en 2022 y ahora ese mismo crecimiento de
4,3 pasó al 2,6 por ciento algunas
economías latinoamericanas registraron
previsión a la baja entre ellas brasil
el organismo afirma que la alta
inflación el aumento en los tipos de
interés ralentizan la economía propósito
qué es tan previo a su jornada electoral
también la economía chilena pasó del 35
por ciento estimado el pasado diciembre
a un 14 por ciento también a la baja
entre las causas para chile dice la ocde
está la retirada del estímulo fiscal la
caída en los salarios reales impulsadas
por las fuertes presiones inflacionarias
y el endurecimiento de las condiciones
financieras
otra economía a la baja es méxico raúl
ese país crecerá 1,9 por ciento en 2022
desde el pronóstico previo del 2,3 por
ciento esto por la inflación dice la
organización y una recuperación desigual
aunque hay positivismo para algunos
países en américa latina sobre todo para
argentina y esto pese a su inflación
crónica y para colombia también hay una
proyección hacia el crecimiento bueno no
estamos tan mal entonces aquí en
colombia jorge pero también el organismo
señaló un importante aumento en la
inflación según este informe la
inflación pasaría de un 37 por ciento de
media en 2021 al 85 por ciento en 2022
laude agrega que la inflación seguirá
siendo alta incluso en 2023 con un 6%
se recomienda en que los bancos
centrales deberían dar una respuesta
monetaria diferenciada según los países
por ejemplo aumentos rápidos de tipos de
interés en eeuu canadá y algunos
pequeños países europeos donde la
recuperación tras el kobe estaba de
cierta forma avanzada y ajustes más
graduales donde la inflación subyacente
es baja y el impacto por el embargo la
energía rusa es todavía mayor el informe
señala una amenaza de falta de alimentos
que acecha a los países pobres o
emergentes de áfrica oriente medio o
asia central que importan sus cereales
de rusia y ucrania que son los grandes
productores exportadores de estos
grandes así es jorge y la economía por
supuesto en mes ajena a la cumbre de las
américas se le pregunté entonces para
darle seguimiento a estos temas
económicos que se están desarrollando en
esa cumbre américa latina podría ser una
solución a las inversiones que necesitan
en medio de las turbulencias mundiales
tanto para los problemas de
abastecimiento como para reubicar
negocios desde otras latitudes así lo
dijo el presidente del banco
interamericano de desarrrollo mauricio
claver según el banquero los recursos y
oportunidades que ofrece la región y el
caribe pueden ser una solución para esos
problemas de abastecimiento ya sea de
manufactura de asia o de alimentos y
energía en europa escuchemos parte de
sus declaraciones de la guerra rusa en
ucrania para todos los países en acción
con la selección de argentina el
salvador y bolivia
el riesgo-país ha bajado hoy en día
latinoamérica y el caribe se ha separado
de la china en cuestiones de cómo
funcionan las inversiones de inversores
institucionales para los mercados
emergentes eso es una gran oportunidad
tenemos que aprovecharla y para eso hay
que ver políticas buenas incentivos
buenos para inversiones hay discordia
política hay populismo de izquierda de
derechas sin embargo hay un consenso del
empresariado para mudar de ni versión
para mudar esas cadenas de valor mejores
la economía japonesa se contrajo en el
primer trimestre así es la contracción
del pib en esa economía fue del 0,1 por
ciento en el período de marzo
perdón de enero a marzo según los datos
del gobierno japonés la caída se debe a
un reajuste del cálculo del consumo
doméstico que aumentó un 0,1 por ciento
frente al estancamiento señalado antes y
de las importaciones que aumentaron un
33 esto fue una décima menos que en el
informe preliminar que publicaron en
mayo los datos ajustados a la inflación
muestran que la economía nipona todavía
no se recupera los niveles pre pandemia
tras alternar avances con retrocesos
trimestrales desde inicios de 2021 el
gasto de los hogares que supone el
principal componente del producto
interno bruto nipón se revisó una décima
al alza hasta el 0,1 por ciento en enero
marzo que nos trae como cifra el día
jorge bueno la cifra es 800 por ciento
en 2029 eso es lo que aumentó el costo
de los eventos extremos relacionados al
clima en 2021 el costo económico de los
fenómenos meteorológicos extremos fue de
aproximadamente
329 mil millones de dólares en todo el
mundo para darnos unidades entre el 2000
y el 2002 la onu no necesita necesito
unos 1.600 millones de dólares en
financiamiento cada año para proyectos
humanitarios tras fenómenos
meteorológicos pero esa cifra se
multiplicó en el 2019 2021 buscó en
promedio unos 15 mil 500 millones de
dólares cada año lo que representa el
aumento del 800 por ciento que le
estamos haciendo a nuestro planeta jorge
gracias entonces por toda la información
económica más adelante más economía nos
vamos directo hasta los ángeles una
ciudad que me encanta
[Música]